and we were talking about um footloose
and we were talking about how you could
have just lived your whole life going to
bar mitzvahs
did you say somewhere you hate going to
weddings and bar mitzvahs and stuff
because literally when the dj sees
you're sitting there inevitably they
play footloose and expect you to get up
and do the dance
every [ __ ] time and then what happens
is
there we go let's do it no let's not do
it have you ever tried to do it in the
privacy of your home
no i actually this is really this is
really part of my morning routine i wake
up i put this on
it's you're in great shape but it's got
to work it's really i get i gather the
kids around the family everyone
are you a dancer i mean do you are you a
good dancer i'm okay
how'd you learn how to dance for that
thing a lot of training
i had um a lot of training training
gymnastics i had a you know a couple of
doubles and some things that i couldn't
do
you know it was really i tell you it was
funny i was on the cover of people
magazine
and after footloose after footloose came
out and back then i was like
i was really resistant to the whole
footloose thing because i was a you know
i was an idiot you know
i was young and i thought oh this is
[ __ ] up because now i'm not going to
think thought of as a serious actor
did do you almost turn down the role
because you thought it was not i didn't
turn the roll down i needed i needed the
dough so i definitely didn't turn the
roll was there a lot of money in it now
probably no no no but
i needed any money right you needed
something something yeah
right um you know but i was like i
wanted to be you know de niro and the g
you know you know what i mean and i
didn't want to be the guy from footloose
you know in a way i think in a way it
took a long time for you to overcome
being the guy in footloose it did but
one of the things was that they they
wanted to put me on like magazines and
teen magazines and i was like [ __ ] i'm
like 25 years old
you know i can't be on a team magazine
so finally they talked me into doing the
cover of people magazine
right and i thought to myself i know
i told them i said i'm not gonna dance
okay
i just wanna tell you i'm not gonna
dance in this [ __ ] picture
and so i get to the thing and the
photographer's there
and he's like okay i'd like you to get
up and do some dancing
and i said i'm not going to do that i
told them i got this
well you don't have to do any dancing i
have a trampoline
he has a [ __ ] trampoline i swear to
god
on the set and he and he's he wants me
to like
jump up and go ah it like fly through
the air yeah like
i said no i'm not going to do it because
you know i was cocky and young
yeah but you were smart did you put on
the music i would do that in a second
though if they put me on the cover
you would right you're like hey sure
yeah oh yeah so stick my pants on
exactly yeah so they uh so i said no i'm
not gonna i'm not gonna do it
and he got all pissed off at me and
finally says well i can't shoot anymore
so he walks out and uh they have a
picture of me
sitting there on the floor and if you go
back and look at the thing
they they get my dance double whoa to
uh be on the cover and he's jumping
around
he's like up in the air around me
jumping around i'm sitting on the floor
like an [ __ ] and it says you know
that he did all the fancy footwork so
they kind of like
oh they really yeah they kind of gave it
to me yeah i just can't i just would
love to be with you at a wedding where
i'm just telling you i'm playing the
song if i do dance
right people kind of form a circle
around me and start clapping
like i'm a trained [ __ ] monkey you
know like i mean
it is i literally i i'm not kidding i do
go up to the dj and i said dude
please please you know cut me a break
tonight you know after you become big
from footloose do you start getting
offered like all kinds of dance movies
and everything like that that hollywood
starts your scene yeah right
well the first movie i did after
footloose was
uh quicksilver which was a kind of
ill-fated
bicycle movie yeah the bicycle it was
kind of like the beginning of the
the next uh steady decline for the next
10 years of my career
and uh and and it was like a bicycle
messenger movie and
you know it had nothing to do with
dancing and i was like this is cool
because it was
it was the same producer right and uh i
was riding around new york with the
messengers on a fixed wheel bike with no
helmet no brakes you know just
training and just a lunatic and you know
i was like this is great i'm gonna be a
bike messenger who worked on wall street
i went down to wall street i did the
whole thing
they switched a movie to uh uh san
francisco
where they have very few basement bike
messengers because
the hills are too fast you get a heart
attack
yeah so uh and then they say we got this
one scene that we're adding
it's kind of like a it's cool it's like
a bike ballet
oh no and they made my uh my girlfriend
in the movie a ballet dancer which
no that was cool right and then they
taught me to do like dance moves on a
bicycle oh no
and they because of the success of
footloose right and there is a
there's literally like a bike ballet
where i'm using a trick bike a stun
a stunt bike and i got pretty good i
actually could do some stuff
and she's dancing around me and then
like
like i get her on the bike and i'm so
bad
i mean it's really awful and there's
some songs songs playing i don't know
what song it was
so you know you're seeing in footloose
where you get up in front of the town
council
and you're convinced that you make that
impassioned speech about
uh you know hey dancing should be legal
and dancing should be allowed
in town okay right which by the way did
you break out in hives
i did i was just going to tell you that
how did you hear that i know how do you
remember that i read the sun
the uh that's actually true yeah
are you afraid of public speaking yeah
and it reminded you of public speaking
exactly i don't like public speaking
which is weird i don't like i can't even
make a toast
honestly why don't you i'm so i'm so
afraid
if my kids get married that i'm gonna
have to make the [ __ ] toast
but well okay but but also why wouldn't
you have a guy write you the toast
and then memorize it like an actor does
yeah and be a character yeah
be it be uh you know maybe that's the
secret yeah
maybe that's a secret that never
occurred to you